thank you
[Music]
did someone talk to you right now about
a story about a young boy
he is six years old
he's in Mexico he's with his family
they're on vacation he's really excited
because For the First Time in his young
life
he's going on a zip line
oh it's gonna end so bad that sounds fun
the Mexican zip lines though they're
crazier than the ones here are they way
faster they go faster
aggressively High yeah I did like seven
of them I want to give a trigger warning
if you're if you don't have to watch a
six-year-old die
I gave a trigger one you made I was
gonna watch this dude do something so
fun is that a parent behind them you
can't watch this damn dude when is it
gonna happen
why are they going so slow
nothing's happening
well
now there's ads
okay so wait I think I misread this I
think you know he lives
I miss you [__] face [__] dude how did
he just fall
they don't exactly know they say the
harness broke so I just failed is what
they say sorry the harness failed and
I'm sorry I misread it too the boy lift
so the incident happened last Sunday in
the Mexican state of Nuevo Leon nailed
it and according to family members the
boy's harness broke while he was on the
zip line sending him into an artificial
pool thankfully thank God that was
located below the attraction and that
was the part I didn't read when I was
doing the study for this
[Laughter]
reported the child fell nearly 40 in the
artificial pools yeah yeah and he got
very fortunate with the way that he
landed did you know how to swim
what's that I hope you knew how to swim
no he but he
heated a belly flop his belly was red
yeah
I wonder if he survived because he was
like so small
it could be could be
um but yeah the CH so he was you know
falling the parents were like holy [__]
that's fair his dad said idios Mio
I picked this one up
that'd be oh my God
he had just learned it the night before
at the hotel Barn he was like yeah come
on what do you guys think
good thing we signed those waivers
Rancheros
stupid he's that kind of dad man
so yeah big surprise by the way the
American family is filing a lawsuit
against the Mexican zipline good luck I
thought you gotta do a stingy with your
with your signature on it well they're
not losses don't work over there yeah
why the zip lines are wild so apparently
after the dad says ideas meal and then
he looked around for that little bit of
affirmation from from people around them
um a tourist nearby jumps into the pool
and saved the six-year-old and then
members of the family blame porch poor
training because the dad is too busy
looking for affirmations
pretty good right like a local huh
close your eyes and hear me and say it
again
yeah so jeez man yeah he actually
suffered minor injuries very very
fortunate he's gone kids oh man he's
psychologically damn he doesn't want to
have anything to do with zip lines for a
while of course
just throw them on immediately
yeah just yeah you got to get them over
it you gotta get over it exposure
therapy yeah let's go right back up get
the same exact harness but then just fix
the little spot that broke yeah put it
on them that actually might be the best
thing pull them out of the river and
just go right again right immediately
right away how crappy of a harness does
it have to be to fail while carrying a
60 year old yeah so if people was an
adult yeah if it was an adult it would
have [__] failed immediately you
should have seen what the line was
carrying before this explorled yeah
probably oh [__] it's a person before
wow
because the Big Bloomers man
how do people get so big
San Antonio is the whole difference so
this is the straw breaking the camel's
back now we need to go on a worldwide
diet yeah yeah yeah
so what about the dad though on the zip
line what about the dead I'm rooting for
this yeah for the guy yeah is he
the dad learned like some new terms he
learned medical right he learned a
couple new things on the way but yeah
thankfully the kid was like not really
injured very minor injuries mostly
psychological that's [__] scary man I
hate zip lines he won't do it yeah he
won't do this it's over he says I draw
the line at zip lines son you gotta try
it again come on let's get back out
there yeah what happens when you fall
off the horse you gotta get right back
on he's like it's like they say in Italy
encore
[Laughter]
kid almost died [__]
kind of a crazy story so have you guys
ever done a zip line before I have in
Mexico so have you guys ever fallen off
with it
I've never had an artist Phil
I've done a lot of zip lines here I feel
like they all have in America right
there's probably like like regulations
and like rules that they all have to
abide by for the most safety [__] so
then it all feels kind of the same when
you go to Mexico it's some Next Level
[__] dude they'll have stuff that's like
a hammock you don't even strap down it's
a [__] Hammock zip line that you hook
on and you just go swinging down like
you're a beautiful girl in a picture
piece and you're like 40 feet in the air
you're [__] up there and then the way
you land is on water so you just crash
into water you know I had to get down so
I you do different zip lines but you
keep hiking up and then the only way to
get down they don't tell you this is you
have to repel 400 feet off the side of a
cliff that's an end repel at the end and
then get on the bus that's tight I was
like was that a Cancun uh Cabo Cabo for
us it was like Zip Line after zip line
you want to do it yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and then one of them were just like
can we both go on and they're like yeah
sure and I was like they're just down
for whatever oh yeah it is man but we
just hooked up and just [__] wrapped
each other on and just just yeah they
gave you like a crash course all right
this is what you do and you just uh this
is how you repel in Cabo we were staying
at a resort you know how they have like
jet skis at the beach and [__] they had
um I don't know if you ever been there
when the storming is really bad they put
these red flags at the beach that says
no activities are allowed we went over
the hundred dollars and go do whatever
you want yeah we went over there jet ski
guy and the jet ski guy like was all
like bummed out and we were like oh man
don't feel so bad just because you know
it's all closed and he's like no man my
girl like broke up with me like I'm just
not in mood I just hate that to be here
today and then um he was like if you
guys just want to grab a jet ski I don't
give a [__] just go ahead oh [__] so
then me and my ex got on one and we were
in the [__] waves when it was like
storming and [__] that's kind of sick
immediately regretted it right I could
have [__] died it was too crazy crazy
is there visibility and you can't even
like at that point you can't even go to
an intended Direction without going it's
waterboarding yeah it's choppy as hell
how are you guys on the jet skis for
minutes that's a fall Massacre dude your
[__] testicles was getting [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was that one yeah so
were you like let's turn it back around
yeah I wasn't trying to like be cool
yeah I just feel like no this isn't
right you probably can't have kids
[Laughter]
indoor skydiving
and it is scary because it's like your
little baby you know and then so like
we're all doing it and like when you go
in the center of the fan you're like
flying around whatever and then when I
was like Titus turn you see like the guy
communicate with the fan operator like
bring it down bring the fan girls like
you throw a little tiger he's goes so I
was like oh [__] like what the [__] and
they're like you don't know what the
hell's happening so you're just like oh
I'm trying to be having somebody [__]
jump in but I don't know what the hell's
gonna happen yeah when you see him kind
of just like floating around and they
they keep hands on them the whole time
and you just see this little kid like
but it was scary looking did he like it
no I hated his other one threw it ever
again
like indoor skydiving sucks it almost
seems impossible to like do these things
though doesn't it
does anybody succeed to suing like a
Mexican zipline you feel like suing
doesn't work outside of the U.S yeah
it almost seems like you can't do it I
think you should be thankful that your
kid is safe is alive
that's 43 oh that was [__] up yeah I
thought he was gonna die at the
beginning of the video I thought he did
die but then I realized I just misread
that
laughs
you didn't even see the clip huh nice
eyes I saw him fall and I was like I
will start crying again dude
again we [__] him up after two girls
that's why I don't like to watch videos
in here anymore no I'll watch videos
dude I'll watch that video again you
watch two girls right now watch that
[__] you want to end the video with Nick
watch it
[Music]
hmm